y'all did the dang thing rachel i
loved it so much i can't even tell you
how much i love this movie so good
oh thank you thank you i'm really i'm
really proud to be part of it
yeah um i just have to start out though
by saying again
i appreciate the moment that david
harbor gave us in this movie that kind
of summed up the last year and a half
for a lot of people
myself included and that's when he's
trying desperately to squeeze back into
that suit
he's just a little bit too tight it was
so relatable
yeah the gyms have been closed
yeah yeah it's funny because i'm like
they shot this pre-pandemic how did they
know
to give us that moment that we all said
i see you
yeah and you know for molina who hasn't
seen david's
character for i think like 20 years or
something he's really
he's really let himself go but she she
still finds him as hot
as 20 years ago when he was a spelt
young man yeah she's she's really she's
very hot for the red guardian
family back together again
you got fat
how does it feel to finally have this
movie released i was
just talking to dave and i was like i
came to the set of this film and it was
like maybe july
or august of 2019 i mean it's a
tremendous relief that it's um safe
again now to i'm so glad that
you know that marvel waited for to open
it in the cinemas when it was safe to go
out again and the idea of
congregating with a big group of
strangers in a big dark cinema with a
big box of popcorn and just going on the
ride of this movie it's very it's a very
emotional thought
i feel like you're right you're reading
a love letter to me popcorn
movie everything like it just feels so
good to be able to you know finally ease
our way back into
a little more normalcy for sure so in
the movie melina
um holds on to a photo book of natasha
and elena like
when they were kids you're a mama so
what is that momentum my mother
keeps everything am i i'm 46 i'm like
mom you can throw that stuff away now
but what's a memento that you hold on to
like as a reminder when your kids were
little that you never want to get rid of
um i have a lock of my son's hair
uh he he's a brunette now but as a as a
baby he had
white blonde curly hair so i have i have
a block of hair and a lot of glass
blocks which
i what is the last year
uh like year and a half been for you
guys at home i mean
um we know daniel's not james bond at
home but i just have this picture in my
head like james bond
lives you live with james bond that's
pretty cool well i mean guys it's been
such a
hard year isn't it for planet earth and
still not
still not over in in many countries in
many places but
listen we were incredibly fortunate we
were safe
we were at home we did a lot of cooking
we we've been safe and well and we're
incredibly lucky and just yeah i just
hope it all
um it's all over everywhere soon yeah
same here um one of the things that i
really well i guess everything i loved
about this movie is that it gave me
everything marvel that i needed you know
it was larger than life
the fight scenes were amazing had a lot
of heart was very very funny
but i want to hone in on those fight
scenes because you got to kick some butt
so what was that like was the training
like how actually how much fun was it
though to be such a badass as well
yeah you know those suits those uh black
widow suits they make they just make you
feel
quite badass they make you stand up in a
particular way and you get these big
boots and shoulder pads and
weapons on your back and cuffs and yeah
it's it
it's very iconic isn't it that outfit so
um
uh it was it was just
great fun uh to choreograph fight scenes
and
um to make i think i'd be a terrible
fighter in real life but yeah it gets
choreographed and
yeah it's it's fun it's fun it's very uh
very escapist
if molina met bond in a back alley who
would come out the other side
i think they both would with cuts and
bruises
yeah they would cheers at the end and
walk off in the sunset i like that
i like that so much this was a joy
rachel i appreciate you i agree with
david he said you're like
the actress for our generation just so
awesome
he did well he's just i mean i think you
can see on the screen
the fun that we had our characters had
together i just
yeah it was very very hard not to laugh
like and my characters as you know
intensely serious
but he would just improvise things a lot
of them ended up in the movie and
it would just be like you just have to
hold yourself together because he's so
damn funny here's what's going to happen
natasha don't
slouch i'm not sludging you're going to
get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
[Music]